[Applaus]
[Musik]
so meine Damen und Herren uns zugeschaltet ist
jetzt Gott der letzte der noch glaubt dass wir
das schaffen grüß Gott Herr klug unsere Herzen
sind weit aber unsere Möglichkeiten sind begrenzt
das sagt ihr Angestellter Joachim gaug also ich
kenne den Mann nicht er kennt mich offensichtlich
auch nicht und ich sage ihn eins er wird mich
kennenlernen wollen Sie etwa bestreiten dass
die Kommunen überlastet nein natürlich nicht
weil die zu viel mit sich selbst zu tun haben
müssen weil ihr es geschafft hat den jahrelang zu
wenig Geld zuzugestehen aber fakt ist doch dass
Deutschland sich einfach nicht mehr geflüchtete
leisten kann ihr ihr ihr seid doch ein reiches
Land aber das stimmt doch nicht wir sind mit
unserem Bruttoinlandsprodukt pro Kopf nur auf
Platz 20 weltweit ihr seid die viertreichste
Nation der Welt aber nicht pro Kopf es gibt ja
sehr viele arme hier aber dann ist der dann
ist der Reich zum falsch verteilt dann geht
er mal vorbei bei den 200 Milliardären oder
über 1,5 Millionen Millionären ja mein Gott
aber dann gehen die doch weg wohin sollen
die denn Weggen na Weg alle irgendwohin wo
sie keine Vermögenssteuer zahlen müssen
oder überhaupt keine Steuern dann gehen
also über 1,5 Millionen Deutsche Millionäre
auf die ceninsel ja dann kommen da also auf
einen kaimana über 25 deutsche Millionäre ja das
sind ja viel zu viel geflüchtete deutsche dann
werden die Einheimischen die deutschen hassen
und davor müssen wir die deutschen schützen
also gut aber wenn dann die deutschen Millionäre
Deutschland verlassen dann werden ja auch einige
Wohnungen frei und nicht die schlechtesten wir
können niemand mehr aufnehmen Deutschland ist
voll verstehen sie das nicht wir sind voll und
Arm ja aber der leherstand der Wohnung beträgt
etwa derzeit in Deutschland 600.000 Wohnungen
lieber Gott konkrete Vorschläge führen jetzt
auch nicht dahin wo ich mit diesem Interview
hin will ich will ja nur sagen wenn ihr wollen
würdet dann dann könntet ihr mehr tun wir wollen
aber ja ja gut aber vielleicht könntet ihr ja das
können wir nicht warum macht nicht einfachum nicht
aber ist es nicht möglich ist nicht wollen sie das
Inter vielleicht mit sich selber führen das ist
der erste vernünftige Vorschlag Herr klug die
gesamte Migrationsdebatte im deutschen Fernsehen
wird ja ohne Migranten geführt ist das richtig
nein das ist überhaupt das ist richtig auch da
können wir niemand aufnehmen sie sind also auch
der Meinung wir können niemand mehr aufnehmen Herr
klug ist richtig Herr klug wir sind voll und wir
sind arm Arm und voll soweit Herr klug Experte
für voll und Arm danke für diese differenzierte
Sichtweise ich danke Ihnen Herr klug ich
danke Ihnen Herr [Applaus] [Musik] [Applaus]
klug tolles Interview Olf ich hab gehört
die Journalisten haben gesagt du wärst fast
leidenschaftlich gewesen dieses Kompliment kann
ich Ihnen gerne zurückgeben für Interview in der
Welt das fand ich besonders besonders freue
mich auf alle Fälle sie Gott persönlich in
meinem Büro begrüßen zu dürfen ja dann sagst du
vielleicht noch deinem Gesicht bescheid ich kann
ihn versichern dass ich bereits gelächelt habe
ich kann mich nur nicht erinnern wann es muss
sehr lustig gewesen sein Olaf wir müssen endlich
im großen Stil abschieben kanzlerchen wenn mir die
Frage erlaubt ist what the [__] ja zunächst
mal vielen Dank für die Frage genau genommen
habe ich gesagt wir müssen diejenigen abschieben
die kein Recht haben in Deutschland zu bleiben
wie diejenigen z.B 2019 konnte hamdia alnim
mit ihrem zweiten Sohn aus dem Irak zu ihrem
Mann nach Deutschland Nachkommen auch der ältere
Sohn war schon da weil ihr Mann zwischenzeitlich
gestorben ist hat sie ihr Aufenthaltsrecht
verloren ein neuer Asylantrag wurde abgelehnt
jetzt ist sie nur noch geduldet aktuell bis Ende
Januar ich hoffe bleiben in Deutschland die neuen
strengeren abschieberegeln könnten sie treffen
man muss die Kraft haben Menschen zu sagen dass
sie nicht hier bleiben können weißt du was ich das
letzte Mal gemacht habe als mich die Menschen so
enttäuscht haben ich habe es Tage und 40
Nächte regnen lassen und alle Lebewesen
von diesem Erdboden getilgt sie meinen sie haben
sich der Probleme entledigt indem sie Menschen
haben ertrinken lassen ja technisch aber das
ist jetzt nicht der Punkt wer möchte denn die
seenotrechtung nicht mehr finanzieren einigen wir
uns auf Unentschieden me ich kann die Emotionen
in dieser Debatte durchaus nachvollziehen
ich bin ja kein Unmensch was was soll das
sein ein ctsan die Ärzte sind sich so 93% sicher
dass ich ein Herz habe man weiß nur noch nicht
wo ich bin nicht hier um an Gefühle zu appellieren
ich bin hier um zu sagen das Asylrecht ist kein
Akt der Barmherzigkeit das Asylrecht ist
ein dem Grauen des Zweiten Weltkrieges
abgetrotztes Recht und deswegen heißt es
auch Asylrecht und nicht Asyl Schaum mal
wir werden auch weiterhin jenen Menschen Schutz
bieten die vor politischer Verfolgung oder
Krieg davon laufen wir wollen nur die irreguläre
Migration unterbinden dann ist ja alles klar nur
eine Frage noch was ist irreguläre Migration
jede Migration die nicht regulär ist hör auf
rumzuscholzen damit sind Personen gemeint die
keine Aufenthaltsrecht oder Duldung in Deutschland
haben moment mal schau mal schau mal schau mal
die Menschen auf auf der Flucht die haben kein
Visum deswegen keine Möglichkeit Deutschland
regulär zu erreichen deswegen müssen sie es
irregulär betreten ja und ihr zwingt flüchtende
quasi Recht zu brechen um Recht zu bekommen wie
sollen wir denn sonst Asylsuchende stigmatisieren
schauen Sie wie eine unbegrenzte Zuwanderung will
der muss auch so ehrlich sein zuzugeben dass wir
dann unseren Sozialstaat nicht aufrecht halten
können ja haben deswegen dein Justizminister und
ein Finanzminister in der Welt einen Gastbeitrag
geschrieben wo sie vorgerechnet haben dass
ich die Leistungen aus dem Asylbewerber
leistungsgesetz nä auf 6,5 Milliarden Euro
summieren die Zahl ist korrekt ja allerdings
die Abschaffung des dienstwagenprivilegs
alleine brechte 5,5 Milliarden Euro christian
lindter hat auch gesagt unmögliches können
wir von niemandem verlangen auch nicht von
uns das ist ein Satz das ist z Satz was Christian
lindnerlings nicht unmöglich erscheint ist die
Absenkung der Leistung für Asylsuchende auf
Null Kinder Kinder Kinder warum haben Sie
nicht eigentlich gesagt wer das halt an unseren
Grenzen nicht akzeptiert ist ein Angreifer und
gegen Angreifer müssen wir uns verteidigen
ich halte es politisch nicht für klug hier
unmenschliche Positionen von Frau Storch aus dem
Jahr 2016 zu diskutieren stimmt ihr habt ja noch
die unmenschlichen Position von Jens spah aus
dem Jahr 2023 der zufälligerweise kurz nach ihrem
Interview ges sagt hat dass W die Migration an
den EU Außengrenzen mit physischer Gewalt stoppen
müssen das wäre das erste Mal dass ein Interview
von mir bei irgendjemandem irgendetwas ausgelöst
hätte ich strebe einen breiten gesellschaftlichen
Konsens an ja ein Deutschland Pakt mit dem Teufel
ja Friedrich Merz ist wohl kaum der Teufel
stimmt aber immer wenn er über Migration spricht
dann riecht er so nach Schwefel ich schlage
vor aufzuhören mit dem Finger auf andere zu
deuten wir sollten gemeinsam anpacken wie beim asl
Kompromiss von 1992 das war eine überparteilich
getragene demokratische Politik ja das war eine
Politik die auf einen rechten Mob reagiert hat
indem sie das deutsche Asylrecht geschleift hat
hören Sie das das ist wie wenn wenn wenn dir dein
Hund ans Bein pinkelt du ihm ein cotlet gibst und
dich dann wunderst dass du am nächsten Tag wieder
nasse Füße hast mir geht es um die Lösung eines
konkreten Problems und das Problem heißt 300.000
geflüchtete aber ihr braucht doch jedes Jahr
400.000 weil weil weil weil die Leute in Rente
gehen die babybomer ihr braucht Ärztinnen und
Ärzte Pflegerinnen und Pfleger Ingenieurinnen
und Ingenieure ja diesen Gedanken habe ich in dem
Interview auch geäußert ja er war in dem selben
Kopf der auch den Gedanken geäußert hat es sind
zu viele das ist richtig natürlich brauchen wir
Zuwanderung ja aber es kommen doch Leute und
die haben auch Talente ja aber die wollen wir
nicht deswegen streichen wir die Gelder für die
bundesweite Studienberatung für zugewanderte und
geflüchtete okay okay hab's nicht anders
gewollt darf ich im Namen der Bundesbürger
fragen was sie da getan haben Gott ja ich
habe im großen Stile abgeschoben so Herr
utoff haben sie abonniert Glocke gedrückt
was sich eines von den beiden Videos hier
angeschaut h sie es reicht mir vollkommen
dass ich in den meisten mitspielen muss
her glauben Sie dass es die richtige Art
ist für uns Werbung zu machen werde ich dafür
bezahlt nee was zum Henker mache ich dann hier
er ist sonst nicht so sie können sich ja
in der Zwischenzeit was ohne ihn anschauen